session to
exchange on the main theme of their
workshop which is computational
challenges
in very large scale omics
and i would like to thank our seven
panelists for accepting to lead the
discussion so i'll give very brief
introduction to each of them so we have
anna konesa who is a research professor
at the spanish national research council
alejandra medina rivera who is a
principal investigator at the
international laboratory for human
genome research of the university
autonomous of mexico
we have katie pollard who is the
director of the glasgow institute of
data science and biotechnology and also
professor
at
ucsf
davide riso who is associate professor
of statistical sciences at the
university of padova
oliver steigel who is associate group
leader of the german cancer research
center and also affiliated with embell
and heidelberg
tandi warno
professor and associate head of the
department of computer sciences at the
university of illinois
urbana-champaign and then shipping wine
who is professor of biochemistry and
molecular biotechnology
at the university of massachusetts
so um i'd also like to thank um
you know all the participants for
responding to our survey and follow
their insightful comments
on the questions that we asked so before
giving a mic to our panel and to just
get the discussion going i've tried to
summarize
um some of the answers that that we got
to the survey
so um one of the questions that we asked
was what are the most exciting questions
in um omics
and here are some of the answers that we
got um one of them was definitely all
the possibilities that the new
technologies open up so third generation
sequencing spatial image stands all
assays and we heard already about that
in the talks
earlier today
another
exciting area of research is the
integration of all these multimodal data
sets to get a better understanding
of biological systems the integration of
sample and population level data and
also the translation to the clinic and
we'll have more of that in a session
later this week about the clinical and
medical application
we also had a question about the
challenges and um from the answer it's
clear that one of the challenges to keep
up
with the technologies and the methods
there's a lot of rapid developments in
the field
and a lot of challenges related to data
in particular the availability and the
accessibility
of data that are being generated
the quality of the data we have missing
data as well
the fact that there are very
heterogeneous data formats and to some
extent a lack of standards for storing
and accessing the data
normalization and sparsity
um
there are also a lot of challenges
related to how we analyze these data in
particular how we assess the statistical
properties
of computational methods and algorithms
how we assess the quality of the results
that we get from the data and the
methods so a lot to do in terms of
benchmarking
um very
a lot of challenges related to causal
inference so um
analyzing perturbation response data
defining outcomes handling confounders
um there were some comments also about
how we needed to have a cultural shift
in biomedical research where we think
about modeling upstream
rather than downstream of the study
design and experiments
a lot of comments about computational
reproducibility
dealing with scaling of the methods to
handle these very large data sets and
also practical aspects related to the
cost
of storage and and computing resources
um we had a question also about how we
can educate
the next generation of scientists to be
able to deal with all these challenges
and one of the themes and the answer was
the importance of multi-disciplinarity
and i think we have that already
reflected
in the audience and in the speakers for
this workshop in particular there needs
to be greater communication and
collaboration between biologists
computer scientists and statisticians
it's very important for the
statisticians and computer scientists
still learn
about the domain
the questions that they're trying to
address with the computational methods
also to understand the limitation of the
data the biases and the noise
exploratory data analysis data cleaning
are very important we heard about that
today with yours um nurse talk
um there's a need for workflows that
manage computational reproducibilities
portability and scalability so we need
to train our students to be able to
develop these workflows
um how can we do that so a few people
mentioned having summer schools like
what we have today
and and there were comments also about
we need to empower students to be in the
driver's seat
and enter the interdisciplinary teams
and then our last question on the on the
survey was about the uh the roles
and relationships between academia
industry and government
um so in terms of academia some of the
roles that were mentioned was the
development of new ideas and methods
basic research
the industry roles that were mentioned
were the generation of major
applications and resources translational
aspects
of research standardization and scaling
for governments the roles that were
mentioned was the regulation to ensure
fairness and privacy but not too much
regulation to
um funding for high-risk basic research
and then encouraging collaboration and
data sharing
um there were some comments
to note that
there were still very
siloed areas
of
involvement of these three
entities they have different strengths
and weaknesses there are some successful
examples of public private partnership
but more needs to be done in that area
and
the respondents noted that really
ideally these three bodies should work
together to advance science
so a few of the take-home messages in
this last slide
are there clearly a lot of exciting
questions
and challenges in omix
it's hard to keep up with fast-paced
development of new biotechnologies
and methods
data accessibility quality and
integration are key
so we have data we have methods
but how good are the results can we
trust the results
we need to have collaboration more
collaboration with teams of experts from
the relevant disciplines and also
greater collaboration between academia
industry and government so this is just
a summary of the responses and now um
i'd like to turn it over to our
panelists and with the first question
and see what they have to say about that
so what are the most exciting
questions
which
would you like to go first
thank you
most exciting question okay so um
but i guess that the exciting questions
are also very much dependent on what is
your field right
so um
i think that i can probably talk about
the exciting questions on the
on the things that i do of in this in
the field that i i i work more
um
these days i'm working a lot on uh third
generation sequencing technologies for
transcriptome analysis
and i think this is creating
exciting uh
possibilities for for research
one of the things that i am seeing here
is that
these methodologies for me they are
changing the way i'm looking at a gene
expression and then transcriptomes
uh because they are offering you a kind
of uh
uh mind-blowing uh
view of of
of transcriptomes as a very dynamic uh
uh process and we have been talking a
little bit alpha and they have been uh
talks about us too and i think that they
are going to be uh challenging the way
in which we define what is a
transcriptome we are used to uh think of
uh
uh of uh for reference annotations of
expressed
genes and transcript that have a defined
structure
and then i think that these
technologies will be uh
indicating that is really a very dynamic
process and then we have to learn how to
annotate this dynamic process and
create
like the the reference annotations how
we are going to be doing that in the
future i think that's going to be a
challenge
uh when we are seeing experiments on
these technologies they are generating
and they are claiming that they are
having
and like
tens of thousands of new transcripts
have been expressed in human are we
gonna be really annotating all these i
think that's uh that's that's going to
be one of the questions that we have to
address in the future
uh
but probably also is the same you know
for for single cell data so what's
how we annotate the the the data that we
uh obtain from from this experiment so i
think that's that's a that's a question
right because
the the huge amount of diversity that we
are seeing with every single experiment
this is something that we want to report
so what what do i have to keep and what
do i have to discard that will be kind
of a
question
and
in connecting with that for me also very
important uh question is
how we translate all these models and we
have seen a lot of modeling here today
into actual understanding of the
underlying biology and that's true for
multi-modal data but in general for data
i think that we are very good in
creating
you know networks and creating
distributions and
of goods i think that we are doing this
a lot but if you think of from all the
today's sessions so what what where the
biological insights that were clear
actually we have been talking very
little about that right so maybe there
was you know one exon here that was
somehow related to audism but
but that's not really uh bringing us
much closer to understanding
biological mechanisms and biological
processes
so i think that we have to do much more
in that area because we have data a lot
of data we have models
but understanding of the biology i think
that this is where we are still failing
and in connection with that
uh
i think that there has to be so
we really need to have uh much more the
uh
experts in biology
uh being part of the
data intensive research
and we have been talking about of the
about education and so forth uh
i think it's great to have
multidisciplinary teams i think that's
great and we need that but i think i
also think that
uh especially biologists need to have uh
education that is data intensive and
that the the data
intensive field becomes part of of the
education program especially in biology
because we cannot do biology anymore
anymore if it's not data intensive right
so the collaboration is great but i
think that we need to have that uh
that's a component there and i'm gonna
be stopping now and
letting other people don't thank you
very much for all this quite annoying
yeah i just wanted to jump in on the
point about mechanisms briefly and then
we should all take turns talking um i
think that was a really great point i
work
mostly in the area of genetics and how
changes in dna change
cause changes in phenotype like what
makes a human different from a
chimpanzee or what does somebody get
sick and someone else doesn't
and
we've had tools for a while to at a
population level if variants are common
enough and effect sizes are big enough
to sort of associate genetic changes
with phenotypes but not to really
understand this mechanistic steps
through which that happens and i feel
like understanding the mechanism is the
key if we actually want to use that
information for good
and so
um very excited right now i think we are
at a time that just was not possible
until recently to be able to go
from
genome to sort of
phenotypes of the genome itself like
epigenetic features 3d genome folding
they're great models now that predict
those things very accurately from single
nucleotide changes in dna
from there to things like gene
expression or other cellular phenotypes
from cellular phenotypes to tissues and
tissues to organisms
i think
that we're a lot of the field does one
of those little pieces and and the
exciting thing for the next 10 years is
to actually put all of those things
together so like jian and i both work a
lot on that first step of dna these deep
learning models and we can like you can
give me any genetic variant and i can
tell you what it'll do kind of thing
right um but then how do we go from that
to like the cellular phenotype cells to
tissues tissues to organisms
in a mechanistic way i think is very
exciting and that's a fun open challenge
for all of us that to try to think about
how to solve very vigorously
go ahead tandy
i'm going to follow up on katie very
briefly so i'm really interested in
similar ideas but pushing deep evolution
so being able to do deep evolution means
you have to be able to do things where
there's the evolutionary processes are
much more complex
we have a lot of models for doing this
we have a lot of software for doing this
but the models haven't been
reinterpreted in the in the aim of going
to deep evolution and they haven't been
really made more realistic and so to be
able to really go at the tree of life
which isn't a tree
but a network but to be able to do this
we need much more biology informed
modeling
and we need we need to take advantage of
these assembled genomes so there is a
potential
for real breakthroughs in how
organisms evolve
how they co-evolve how they adapt to
their environments in detailed ways that
we can't do now but we need to do much
more about the modeling and then the
inference methods
so i'm very excited about the
possibilities
could i add um from
what katie said earlier so i think um
i think we're at the point that we can
um answer something that's really i
think really important which is the
differential question
so if you look at the cell if you look
across the transcriptome um
it's
reasonably easy to predict the different
expression of genes
um
within a transcriptome but i think the
differential
between two different kinds of
transcriptome maybe between patients and
controls
between two perturbations
um that's much much harder to predict
like it's easier to maybe predict the
differential from variance
to
open chromatin maybe 3d chromatin
structure but by the time we go to
differential expression
like among the projects we have looked
at the
predictability of differential
expression is really bad
so somehow um these
sequences sequence to expression
precisely yeah we could do the middle
step exactly
exactly so i think
yeah that is with the data we have right
now across single cell
more causative modeling we add a step to
answer this question which i think
is is going to make a big difference in
our understanding
yeah i mean just to
quickly add to this i think um
what's also really nice you know seeing
over just today is you know how we can
piece the different elements together
right i mean from you know sequence to
accessibility transcription the other is
also regulatory networks you know how
genes dependencies on how they
interlinked
and how we can bring bring those
components into bringing this and i
think what in the end should be really
an interesting goal is there's a look at
how we can use the data to understand
how tissues function yeah and and going
you know the next step i think going to
an organism is maybe
you know at least a complex organism a
big step but at least um
at a sort of um
tissue level uh communication i think
there there's a lot to be done by
combining regular networks
variation to accessibility to
transcription
and causal discovery spatial omics which
i think we'll hear about more later
would be very important to understand
how
cells interact in context and towards
causation and
um what
maybe could think about as a community
as well how we could hear our modeling
and approaches that these individual
problems we're solving
that they are designed in such a
plugable way that we can teach them
together
to be bigger models i'm not talking
about simulating a whole cell type of
approaches that i think very ambitious
but i think we see more towards that you
know that we can piece
individual modeling components that
solve sub problems we still heard a lot
about very specific sub problems today
how we can piece those together to solve
bigger problems and
that's also something to think about how
to foster this interoperability of these
these components that this is possible
common languages
you know do we use probabilistic program
frameworks i think that's an important
question to be able to do what you all
alluded to which i completely agree with
yeah so i completely agree and i and i
think that um
we have to rethink a little bit what we
do when we do like data integration
right now right now a lot of these data
integration things are like just uh
looking for shared latent variables
right but like to me the real power of
putting together all these technologies
is like for example have a high c data
and i can predict ads and then then i
look for announcers only within the todd
because i know that they're kind of like
uh enriched there so like uh trying to a
little bit like what the other panelists
have said like putting back the sort of
biological question at the beginning
right and then trying to use these as
tools to answer a real biological
question rather than just we have a
bunch of data and we want to kind of
like see what the data tell us right um
the other thing that oliver mentioned
briefly is like spatial transcriptomics
right and so going back to the original
question
um to me that's very very exciting new
technology that um will be very
transformative in the next few years
you know especially
uh like for example leary and his talk
had this murphy uh data and i think that
those like uh murfrees type of uh
technologies are really great because
they can give you like even like
subcellular uh sort of like transcript
uh
coordinates of of the you know the
different transcripts and how they
interact and then like the bigger
question of like how cells interact to
each other and and
that to me
you know
it's also kind of transformative in the
sense of how we deal with data like
these are huge images that are going to
require like you know
terabytes of of space and like we want
to probably like quickly being able to
have like a bird's eye view to look at
like how cell interact and then zoom in
in a cell and see how transcripts
interact that i don't think we have like
the bioinformatic
knowledge to be able to do that in an
efficient way yet so i think that that
would be interesting to see how the
field moves into that direction
[Music]
all right just quickly and already
mentioned this a bit but one of the
challenges also will be how do we
agglomerate all these datasets that are
being generated and then the issue won't
be even the fact that they were done by
different labs or different machines or
technologies it would be that they are
not even annotated in any similar way
so metadata is one of the major channel
challenges now in
in these endeavors because there is data
that's useless useless because you have
100 libraries and you don't even know
who's male female or patient on control
because they just submitted a table
saying 50 and 50.
and that's useless
so how also as a community can
push our collaborators or ourselves
towards annotating data in a more
consistent way so we can someday use it
all together and create
really complete maps and atlases
i think we've already jumped to the
challenges already so mostly you know
the exciting problems and the challenges
are clearly succeeded so we've got a lot
of
insight
yeah
maybe maybe i can still maybe maybe we
have enough data to understand some
diseases because
i think if you compare patients versus
controls very often
a lot of things are different
but i doubt all of them matter
so if you want to have some kind of
treatment
if you could find out what's going on
and
what really matters um i think that
could be an interesting challenge so
that we can just target
therapeutics toward
the
the difference that matters
yeah i want to bring up a challenge as
sort of a cultural challenge in science
which um is that all of you very smart
people
i bet like 99 of the time are looking at
data after an experiment has already
been done maybe you helped design the
experiment a little bit but we are
either mining public databases a
collaborator comes and asks for help
or something along these lines and so
imagine instead that all the modeling
people
were
um
had some great models that linked you
know sequences to epigenetic features
and to phenotypes all the things we've
just been talking about and our models
could generate hypotheses and those
hypotheses were is what was driving data
collection
now that sounds like not that crazy but
it actually is kind of crazy because
nobody wants to do that
like it's just there's a huge cultural
resistance to it
and so the the challenge i see is for us
to
develop some examples where that works
really well
and we get a lot more value out of the
data that was generated than if we had
just been playing a more passive or
downstream role as soon as we have a
couple of really big examples and i'm
i'm saying this because i'm very
confident that that having modelers
driving the process would make a huge
difference if we can do that and show
that we
predict something awesome like you were
just describing sleeping
um people will pay attention
maybe just a comment on that i think
this is very uh
achievable
i mean the one hand because um
the culture is slowly changing you know
computation becomes more data driven but
also technology i mean soon you know
there are now technologies high
throughput perturbation screen other
elements where
it's just no longer feasible to make
attack choices about what perturbations
to consider you know you know modeling
based design criteria for experiments
will be more and more important so i
think we have to work collectively to be
in the loop to really put
the computation ultimately even
objective algorithmic decision functions
into the decision point of this
and i think also when selecting projects
projects where this is a goal
i think are maybe also more future
directed something we could focus on you
know so this is i think a really really
achievable vision and i i completely
agree yeah that there's something on it
um
[Music]
so
i think well
you just wanted to add one
additional component um
so we have been seeing here some um
some talks uh relating to uh you know to
measurements of uh in in large of more
or less larger
patient cohorts and then we are looking
at the genomes and of the single cells
there are initiatives
all over the place of sequencing more
and more and more individuals with the
hope that we can then find the variants
that are associated to uh to diseases
and i think this this
is generating a huge amount of data that
will be very valuable but i think that
we are really missing
a very important part of the equation
which is
the measurement of the environment of
these individuals so we know that
phenotypes is a genome plus environment
right so uh and in many of these uh of
diseases that are hyperbalance diseases
there is a very strong environmental
component
um that is on top of the genetic
variation
and i know that we have been
you know and people working on uh
putting together all the health data and
all the information that is available
for for for this patient that you are
sequencing
but actually there is a lot of this
environmental impact
that we are not measurement that is you
know the lifestyle of the of the of the
the person their life history so where
have you been what have you done what
have you eaten how you have exercised
which air have you breathing you know
everything that is around you um that
actually is having a huge impact of
what's what's happening to you right
and um i think that now we are entering
a a an era in which you know there is a
lot of monitoring systems
around us and i think that we also need
to know how to leverage this data
to integrate it with the molecular
informations to really come into
predictive models of the phenotype and i
think if we don't really think of how
systematically measure
the environment
[Music]
i mean we can make we we can sequence
millions and million million of
individuals but i don't know we will get
there
yeah oh sorry
okay so i'll be quick i actually sort of
said this earlier but the challenge that
i want to bring up is related to what i
think is also the potential so in my own
area which is phylogeny estimation
people do phylogeny estimation using
standard models that have been around
for decades
and the assumption is that it's good
enough the assumption is that it's just
a question about np hardness and coming
up with the effective heuristics and
it's fine
i actually don't think it's fine and i
think that we really need to have some
concern about
those estimation problems where we don't
really know what the right biological
model is and
other than simulations we don't have
benchmarks and the simulations are
problematic because you simulate under
the model and you test under the bottle
that doesn't tell you much
so i'm actually i really think we need
to get
some concern i think it would be great
if people were worried
because then we might actually test it
so earlier i saw i think it was you you
showed a simulation where you simulate
under a complex model but a simple model
is fine
great
that's not being done in my area okay
even the complex models are simple
and the realism in biology is so much
more heterogeneous than any of the
models so i really get worried about
this and it's even worse for multiple
sequence alignment and that is worse for
genomes
so i think we just need to be worried
instead of assuming we have software as
long as we keep getting the same results
it's fine
[Music]
thanks very much
yeah so i i wanted some perfect points
yeah no i know
i i wanted to react to what anna was
saying but then now i also
but i think they they sort of like uh
they're they're similar which is sort of
like jumping a lot of hat to the
question of like out research sort of
like academia in academia and in
industry and uh they they can sort of
collaborate and i think like for example
a very good example of what you were
saying it's like what 23 and me has been
doing right 23andme has been like
collecting these genotypes of a lot of
people or customers
right and then they they uh keep sending
them questionnaires right and and a lot
of people answer to those right and so
they have a much better idea of their
cohort of you know what they do and if
they come up with a new question to just
send out the new questionnaire of the
email so like that's a good model that
maybe we could
borrow in in academia and you know
going back again to this kind of like
academia industry like i spent maybe
like uh 50 of my time one year of my
post-doc with a startup company here in
the bay area right and like uh
the
and this company had the fda approved
genetic tests for a certain type of
cancer right and the
amount of like um
uh
quality of the data and the modeling
they had to do to in order to pass this
up sort of fda approval is something
that you don't often see in academia
right like in academia it's very often
to see like this sort of double dipping
problem you just run a lot of models on
your date until you know you you get the
one that has the uh highest f1 score or
the rsc or whatever
there they you know if you want to get
actual like fda approval for something
like you have to like just get
part of the data just never what
use it again like and and just you can
do all the training you want on your
training set but then the moment you you
start using your test set then you're
done you cannot touch the model anymore
right so people are much more careful in
like avoiding these sort of like
um uh overfitting problems so
you know these are kind of couple
examples of things that maybe you know
we could learn as you know it would be
nice if there were papers done like that
in academia as well right um
which kind of maybe goes a little bit
beyond just simulations and showing that
simulations work
point to um
what the vitamin d was
starting one one step earlier is the
sort of accessibility and standards for
using common data to solve problems
and there i mean leonis talk highlighted
this resource you know creating this and
i think the other community efforts and
i think
investing in this area could be
something it's maybe also an interaction
with industry where there could be
common interests
to having these resource standards
established
and using them and having data you know
uniformly processed available for
everyone and solving some of the tedious
elements i mean from a european
perspective there are these four magic
letters gdpr which causing us a lot of
headache for human data and
regulation is slightly easier on this
side of the atlantic but um
and you know getting respecting data
privacy but still making data accessible
for small labs but over up and coming
huge regulatory hurdles which companies
can obviously
afford uh by spending money and i think
that'd be very important to solve
solutions that are
of mutual interest to
avoid a lockout that academia can't do
certain things
because the hurdles the expense is just
too high um to get get that implemented
and i think that's a real challenge
where one could ever think about
creative solutions
with commercial entities
i think this is a great discussion and
and
um what i wanted to mention
was that i think it's it's important
that we are not
mixing up um basic research and
translational research
and
translation activities too much
because i mean in in this omics field
many of the data
types and data sets they have been
generated just to see what what they
actually could be used for or not
because uh there was a hypothesis that
you
knew upfront that you would be able to
to to deal with when we switch over to
the translational
aims
i mean there is a whole
regulatory
system
that actually is trying to
control
what you actually exposed to to to the
patients
and
if we have decision support systems we
need to get them approved as medical
devices both in europe and
and here
and and i think that's a good thing uh
because it's uh
it's very dangerous
to to let algorithms run
stuff
without having it replicated in
different countries and find out how how
good these models are so generally
generalized so i think we should
we should discriminate a little bit what
is blue sky
basic research
and
and what are the translation names and
then
i'm sure there are many surprises that
suddenly we can see that something could
reach the translational stage much
faster than we actually had anticipate
but it's still um two different things
then i also wanted to mention one other
thing
and that is that i've heard that
uh i mean almost in all
uh
industries or activities in in society
that that involves technology whenever a
technology
has reached perfection
it's phased out
i mean we when when terrorist speed was
finished
cleaning up the statistical analysis of
spotted arrays
they went away
and and then then every matrix came in
and then
it it it's changed it was a game changer
because now there was a new type of data
with less noise and
and so i think we should get used to it
instead of just expecting that
that all the sort of new developments
that that they can be
standardized up front because i'm not
sure it is possible but these are my two
comments basic research translation but
also
that that
newer approaches
also
thanks very much for these two points
saren and i think david yeah
i want to just uh to briefly comment on
the second point which i think it's uh
very very good and and i think we also
um though shouldn't you know just throw
away everything that we've been learning
from these older technologies right
because like it's a little bit like what
liars showed in in the second part or i
guess the third part of your talk where
you know
there's uh you know for example like
moving one technology further like bulk
rna-seq we learned a lot about you know
negative binomial models and like uh
you know these other sort of
quantitative biology uh fields that are
still very pretty much valid in single
cell analysis and they will be valid for
spatial transcriptomics and for long
read sequencing so um
it's uh you know i remember rafael once
said that you know you guys that do a
single cell rna-seq then you know you
just need to read my stuff and like
quantile normalization of rna-seq and of
micro rays and you'll be fine right
that's all like a special case of that
but it's a little bit like that right we
should uh
don't forget kind of the older
literature especially for methods um
i think that's important
exactly yeah i i think this reinventing
the real is a really
important challenge also
conceptualizing the problems in such a
level
that they can be applied from lots of
settings you know i think this
count matrix
processing problem is a good example as
you mentioned it's around for a while
and probably will be around for some
time but then there are also sub
problems which are more technology to
specific and
i personally find it as a challenge
really hard to
scout out for technology you know which
one is going to be the one you know when
do you jump in developing this book
method which problems solve themselves
we discussed now long read
error rates in nanopore and there's a
question do we develop a model or do we
just wait until the next chemistry comes
out and the rate drops by
an order of magnitude and i think these
sort of decision functions are real
challenges and um
and it's also difficult to decide for
individual scientists in the community
you know where the interface between
technology overriding computational
solutions because they're no longer a
problem
the convolution of special
transcriptomics you know when spots are
substantive resolution maybe you don't
want to leak involved anymore i mean all
these decision functions are not so
trivial
and and there will be solutions have a
longer or shorter longevity and
sometimes it's not so easy to predict
how long the problem will be around
um until a disruptive advance just wipes
it
away so i think that that is actually
remains a challenge you know this
generalizable concept is certainly a
good way to um
make sure your science is future-proof
so to say
[Music]
yeah just to push my other point about
uh models to drive experimental design
or collection of data i i think models
should be driving technology development
we shouldn't be waiting to see what the
next thing is that can be measured
what
what where where are we performing badly
where are the blind spots what piece of
data do we not have and can we
try to
push for that to actually be collected
in the future
well i think that
for most computational biologists has
been the other way around so the
technology came and then we have to
to see what what can we do with that
right so the technology goes ahead and i
agree that i mean we have to to to pose
uh problems to
to technology but the the reality is
that it's kind of the other way around
but
yeah i think that's um
it's it's hard to say i mean if you you
as a computational biology of the
analysis start addressing then you know
the
the error model of the data
and spend time with that and then the
technology advances and then what you
are doing is worthless right so i think
this is something that you have to lead
with because that's gonna be there all
the time and then you have to be fast or
the technology will catch up for sure
right of the technology will put another
problem that's for sure
um
what i'm trying to see it's which are
the things that are kind of
recurrent
through the technology advanced advances
right and um
and yes we are measuring molecules and
we are measuring more and more molecules
and more and more different type of
molecules and and and with different
technologies but
i think there are some things that we
are still
having as challenges that we have not
been able to address properly in the
last 20 years right
and one again i insist this biological
interpretation of the data models right
so
regardless whether your original data
was microarrays or if it was single cell
it's still very hard to create a
mechanistic model
of what you are seeing of the biological
system that you are seeing right so i
think that we are not
progressing fast enough there right and
um and that's regardless of the
technology of how you measure these
and probably is because it's hard for
the human brain to you know to
understand all these molecules working
together right so we need to do to come
up with
more uh um
creative ways of understanding the data
right and um
[Music]
and i was going to be saying something
else but i forgot so maybe we'll come up
to this later but
again so i think that there is one the
technology and the technology goes ahead
right and and then there are some things
that we are kind of
not being
we don't get there
and one of these are the the
interpretation i think is the
great uh
challenge that we have in front of us
uh yeah uh so i just wanted to add um a
couple of points that have been
mentioned sometimes now uh
so when it's like which datasets should
we address
now no like uh and this tempting idea i
was thinking that now we have a lot of
data so we maybe don't need much more to
understand patients and controls but
actually uh
yeah maybe that's true if you are only
focusing in
north european ancestry populations then
maybe that's true
but if you want to learn anything else
about like the other part of the world
then maybe that's completely false
because we also don't even have data on
lifestyles diets that come from any
other place in the world like once i
asked someone from the uk biobank how
would they address diversity and they
told me we have migrants like yeah
migrants have a particular way of life
like they change environments but one of
the other people that's remaining home
those are lost in like in life and
probably will never know what happens in
the disease for that population and in
that environment and
so at some point
that is tempting
and i think at some point it will also
bring information on how
uh the disease interacts with the
environment with the changing
environments if you characterize
different populations for the same
disease you could learn more biological
insights
there's even medicines that are
developed in in the states that promise
for example remission for lupus in six
months that we see at least an
eggnotical that they are not working in
the mexican population we have no idea
if it's just the patient we are serving
or if it's just uh that is actually
there is a difference in the kind of
lupus or in the environment or the
genetics we don't know
so there's still a lot of data that has
to be collected across the globe and
sometimes it's tempting to think that
our methods and the things we develop
work enough in this data and these
models
but maybe we still need to address other
data sets and
actually if
[Laughter]
and i think the message i get from all
of you is that it's not just small
challenges but a lot of
paradigm shifts so that will lead us to
the next question which is how we
we train
the next generation for that and then
get back to the discussion about
government industry and academia and
then finally alejandra another alluded
to that how we make sure that the uh
the research and the education is
accessible to populations
that are typically underrepresented in
science so i'm just making sure we you
know i repeat these three important
questions so that we can you can address
them in whichever order you want because
i i really like the dynamics on the
panel and all the things that are
mentioned so
okay
yeah i just want to add something really
quick about making our efforts and the
research future proof right
i think that's really important there's
nothing worse than spending time chasing
after technology
so i think we should define our research
research problems
broadly enough and then always revisit
it
when new technologies become available
very often we could answer a piece of
the problem but when new technology
becomes available we should we should
say are we answering more
than before are we adding anything
rather than reinventing the whole thing
again
right so with single cell
are we answering additional questions
before them before when we had the bulk
sequencing now we have single sequencing
are we answering actually biological
questions at a higher level so so i i
really like the idea of being future
proof
well maybe i get started i can get
started on education so i mean i guess
i'll give my um somewhat niche maybe um
um experience in the sense that i'm in a
stats department in italy and i think
you know
i'm the only one in this room
but like uh no i mean more seriously i
guess you know
it is obvious
i think to all of us that
interdisciplinarity is the key right so
i've been hearing from other panelists
that you know biologists need to be
trained to uh work with data but you
know if you want to be a good like sort
of bioinformatician or applied by
statistician
it's the other way around too like you
know you have to be trained in like
biology and understanding biological
concepts and um and that's
to me for example that's a struggle for
my students as you know someone in the
stats department which is not in
berkeley which is you know
obviously
much more
um you know advanced in that sense you
know you have the center for
computational biologists there's a lot
of crosstalk between the stats
department and other departments it's
not like that in every university and uh
even you know when i was applying for
faculty jobs in a lot of places they
would just you know tell me i didn't
have a biometric or uh you know a stats
journal publication and
um and that's
still true for my students as well right
so i think
there needs to be somewhat a shift
towards um
accepting sort of like
multi-disciplinarity
as a way to kind of promote students and
promote young faculty and like not as a
you know i feel like in my career i
oftentimes had to work twice as much to
prove that i was like
you know a worthy statistician or in
addition to being like a
bioinformatician and i think if you
change statistician to computer
scientists or to biology it's still true
right i mean if you're a computational
biology maybe you have to prove that
you're still like a true biologist if
you're a computer scientist working in
bioinformatics you still have to kind of
like show that you go to computer
science uh conferences so i think that's
the mind shift that we need to
make sure it happens
i don't know how but like i think you
know
maybe it's a good
discussion point
i just want to completely agree with you
and just want to say
one of the things that's really great in
statistics is you guys actually look at
data
in computer science it's rare
so i think that really getting computer
scientists to work on data early and to
really think about it and to interpret
data
is incredibly informative to their
development
uh but you're right unless the academic
departments can start to value
people who don't look
core like them
it's going to be hard so i think that's
particularly hard in math departments
it's not as bad in cs except some cs
departments are still way behind
um it will be interesting to see what
happens in the future but i think we
need to keep pushing on this and the
academy needs to change
so i have something more on training but
i don't know if someone wants to follow
up on
okay
sorry so so my main worry is is like um
you know it's going to take students
longer and longer
training
until the student becomes productive so
if that period goes to five years we're
all down for right so how do we solve
this problem how do we bring
like education
like as quickly as possible so that we
can start to be productive
so i think that is a challenge in our
field
yeah it related to this comment and also
what david mentioned
i think it's interesting how to define
disciplinarity i mean there's a
plainerity that you work between two
currently classical university
departments but you create new fields
yeah and they're different approaches so
um
uh you know creating new programs
computation biology programs that sort
of live on their own have their own
identity and it's it's not so clear to
me what's the right approach you know
how one when is a new field when do you
spark these fields and
and how do they evolve it or do you
stick to some basic disciplines and then
foster the interfaces between those
and it looks like in our area you know
there's probably everything you know we
have these different bridging between
different classical domains stats to
biology and then there's
new programs like computational biology
their own identity and
um
and i guess one needs to foster
tolerance of these different career
paths which students being able to
switch is very important
i have huge headaches getting my
students registered if they come from
the wrong background have the wrong
whatever
then getting them
you know enrolled in these programs and
these things these hurdles they just
cause frustration um
so really with david that yeah we need
to
figure out how to fix it on the other
hand it's also important that
somehow there is a community that
respects what you do otherwise it
becomes sort of the accountability is
also an issue you have nobody
understands what you're doing he's sort
of lost in between that's also hard to
fix intrinsically
[Music]
i think also that between the
multi-disciplinarity there's the
so at some point
we cannot be experts on anything though
we do have some time to prove ourselves
in many fields to gain some respect but
uh
there is a point where you have to
stop and acknowledge that for some
biological questions you have a
biologist or someone that is really an
expert on that area that you know enough
to interpret the data and to communicate
which is very important
but you won't be the expert in that area
um and i'm i'm really in between all the
time and i think i know enough
computer sciences to understand the
methods and to use them but
i wouldn't be able to create a new one
or modify like the statistics behind
them so i collaborate with people that
are good at that and i acknowledge that
i won't be doing that
thank you very much for the discussion i
just have three points to make regarding
this training i think first of all from
today's talks i think many of us agree
that benchmarking is much needed for our
field but i feel like probably for our
students career development benchmarking
work is undervalued right if a job
candidate has benchmark papers many
people or departments may treat these as
less important than novel method
development that's something we need to
address as a field
and the second point i want to make is
regarding the
interdisciplinary thing because i'm in
the statistics department but i have to
say my department is very open-minded
and i feel very fortunate about that but
one way i found to
interact with my colleagues who are not
in this field is to talk about the
importance of our work or like the
impact of our work because i think
that's something everybody can
appreciate and i think biological
biomedical sciences are particularly
strong for our impacts right nobody will
argue that treating diseases will is not
important
and i think the third point is about how
do we
in our field i can also see we have
people who focus more on algorithms
method development and people who focus
more on biology like answering questions
using computation analysis i think we
need appreciation within our field
because i've seen people who think
developing algorithms may be better
intellectually better but i think we
need to appreciate the importance of
having new biological questions on the
other hand i think for people who focus
more on biology they also need to
appreciate the need for new algorithms
we wouldn't think that everything can be
solved by existing algorithms so i think
within our field this mutual
understanding of appreciation is very
needed
thank you very much
i just want to follow up on that very
good point the there's a big problem
with how do you do how do you evaluate
researchers
um there's too much emphasis on
citations
and if you focus on citations you're
going to think anyone who gets a lot of
biology papers is much more important
than let's say a theoretical computer
scientist
you can't even normalize for field so
it's very tricky and there's something
has to be done so that understanding
contributions is made with greater
intelligence
also in science papers the computer
scientists the statisticians
mathematicians are never first authors
so there's this other issue so i think
this is a complex issue it's
sociological
and it's not going to be answered very
easily
i just wanted to jump in real quick
why did you mention that
about assessing
contribution um you know we're making
progress
i think gradually i mean it's better
than 20 years ago when i was in the job
market and i felt like i had to give two
job talks
a theorem proof
talk and then the applied talk which had
much more impact so but but it's still a
big issue in statistics i was at at the
joint statistical meetings last summer
and there was a whole session devoted to
elevating applied statistics so young
scientists young studies teacher is
still struggling
with that
issue and i think assessing it you know
the contribution you know applied
journals
collaborative
projects and so on so we need to be
better than we're facing this on a very
large scale beyond biology here at
berkeley with the other campuses with
the creation of data science
department so that's a really big topic
and i'm delighted to
hear that being addressed on the panel
so i thought i'd just jump in with that
yeah i already mentioned the key points
actually but i i
i think there's also some
some things in our own hands and when we
write author contribution sections and
we think about papers
to reflect that you know be really
careful about how we attribute credit
and
and also how to guide trainees and how
they write their cvs you know that you
really you know have a couple of papers
where you clearly state what was your
contribution some grant agencies uh now
use this also write down five papers
with contribution sections i think there
are ways to do that but we have to think
also sort of
as a community do the the sort of
bottom-up approach well obviously there
needs to be top structures need to be
fixed and what's clear from this is also
particularly if science is so
collaborative now you know that this
linear author orders it's just sort of
such a thing of the past you know
sometimes
it really doesn't make any sense anymore
and i i really i really like all these
papers where people you know write down
author or determine by coin flip or
other things to just make the point that
this is just insane and
and i think that's that's the mindset we
should all try to sort of propagate and
communicate yeah
oh no i'm just raising my hand i've done
the coin flip okay
well uh maybe we need a benchmark on how
to report the contributions
of the author now and and i'm saying
that because uh in the in the last uh
you know consortium project in which i
was involved
we kind of
made a very strong effort in uh
monitoring the contribution
of everybody and
having kind of
groups of authors that have similar so
we were kind of applying almost a
clustering algorithm to group the
authors based on the contributions that
were in a huge excel
sheet in which we have a contribution
and authors and then you have to put a
cross in which kind of contribution as
an author you have so
and i thought that that was actually a
very interesting uh you know exercise
right um
when uh
maybe we need to have also papers
discussing of which is a good way to to
to describe that uh
so that people can adjust to some kind
of fair guidelines of how to um
to report others
but yeah no i agree um but i i wanted to
go back to to i guess uh oliver's
question about like
whether we need a new discipline or not
and i think in some sense having like a
bioinformatics discipline would be like
uh like recognized at the same sort of
level as you know statistics and biology
and like
that would make our life easier in some
sense right uh the fact that you know we
as a community like we could set up our
own rules on like you know hiring people
and like uh giving promotion and all
that and of course it's also
dependent on the places right for
example i
you know i was in a biostats department
at white cornell and and it was clear
from day one that they you know as body
statisticians we were not expected to be
like you know pi on r1 or like last name
of papers to be promoted to associate
right because they recognize that by
statisticians have a different role um
but it's not like that in every school
right and
um
yeah so i don't know
so there's also a question on so these
new disciplines and that's something
that has been happening in the last 20
years it's uh the creation of like
bachelor level uh new degrees like on
bioinformatics there's some already uh
but from the bachelor level and that
goes into what you're saying shipping
about
when do you start training them so they
can be productive someday
so
yeah exactly so these these bachelors
well those aim to like to
really train people in bioinformatics so
they know the biology and they know the
computational sciences but they are not
expert in in neither
that's my end point
but they can start working and being
like in between the two areas and then
do graduate school and maybe specialize
a little bit more into one side
so maybe that's a solution to start like
um creating these fields from the
bachelor levels and then some they they
will exist as institutes and
that are more inclusive with people that
really understand from the beginning how
this
this area work how this career works
like which kind of papers do you get how
do you well the authorship can be
discussed and it should be benchmarked
that sounds good um
but yeah we if there is a field that
it's being created maybe
it can be already within our programs of
education
yeah i mean i just want to
elaborate on what i said earlier about
training i feel like
students come in you know the data sets
are so big
and so much pre-processing
um normalization
this way that way
and then data quality i mean so much to
learn which is
unprescribed how do we educate students
so that they
can figure it out as quickly as possible
and
get to the point where they can
contribute rather than
mechanically
but intellectually right i mean i feel
like i struggle with my own students
some of them i have to kind of carve out
a project and plug them in and say okay
just work on this part okay just don't
worry about the big picture because if i
don't do that that student is not going
to graduate
but how do we struggle with this kind of
training i think these are very real
issues
i just wanted to give an example
okay i just wanted to give an example of
actually at the university of florida
when i have been a professor for seven
years and
so at some point um the founder of
nvidia who was uh
a graduate student from
[Music]
the university of florida came to the
university and put money on the table to
hire 500 faculty in artificial
intelligence
500.
so uh
what is happening there now is that
there is this movement across the
university in which
every single discipline will have
someone in artificial intelligence
around and that's biology that's
architecture that's uh
even the library you know and the the
the idea uh of the movement that is
going on is that actually all these
quantitative skills
should be part of the curriculum of
every single class
so we are not talking about adding new
classes so that every student will have
to learn i don't know by using
statistics now we are not talking about
that we are talking that if you are uh
working on the in your lab maybe your
lab journal is something that you do in
our i don't know just to give a very
simple example so
that the quantitative skills are
transversals and the quantitative
quantitative way of thinking is
transversals to every single class right
and this is being now implemented
like with a lot of
uh million dollars on on on on on the
system but
um
[Music]
i think that probably we have to think
that in the future and i think that we
are facing and a future in which
um
data is just an integral part of our
lives right so and that's what we are
seeing it's all about data
so that will be part of the curriculum
in a very more transversal ways
not as you know as a particular class
that you you take but something that is
in bed embedded in in every single class
and i think that's how we have to train
the future students
[Music]
yeah and i guess going back to what
alejandra was saying before
like you know i'm
a statistician i still will always be a
statistician i would never have the
biology knowledge of biologists and kind
of like the same for biologists with
statistics i think what we
what we need is sort of like
giving enough
to have a common knowledge and be able
to collaborate and talk the same
language when they you know when the
students for your group and my group get
together to write a paper right
yeah um i've really enjoyed this
discussion just reflecting on what you
have said katie especially but others
also um
you know it's made me thought think a
little bit about the relationship
between biology and physics so i feel
like in physics there are well specified
and really precise models that have very
specific predictions and that allows
people to design experiments
and technology
to test those predictions
and
i just wonder if panelists could comment
on i know it is kind of aspirational to
imagine
developing like really models that are
more in line with physics but i feel
like if we could it could lead us
towards some of the goals that you all
have described
so
i had been leading a large
bioinformatics center for for many years
but then 10 15 years ago i got the offer
to make a large omics effort together
with
a colleague especially in in proteomics
and
but this should be at a medical school i
used to be at a technical university
and
then i started
to do
md psd students
and to turn it around and it's a little
bit what that video also said instead of
us
teaching the students to become
multi-disciplinary
they could also we could turn it around
and and then they could um
teach the teachers uh how to become
knowledgeable about things in in a
different area and and
and
it's been a very interesting experience
because medicine is super
reductionistic for a good reason if you
have one disease you want to focus on
that and what can you do for this
patient we come with our omics mindset
we want to look at all genes and all
tissues all cell types and so on but but
a lot of medicine wants to focus
and so so so that has been a
sort of eye-opener for for me that that
that these md phd students they can
really change your mind
uh about about things and and then it's
also interesting that they run away from
you again because they
they don't want to become computational
biologists they want to go back into the
clinic and become surgeons and many
other things but then they have this
upgrade
in terms of data handling and and mining
patient records and so on so it's it's
so i think like david said we we should
maybe get the um
pis a little bit out of the equation and
and and uh i really liked what you had
on the slide that you should
let young people lead the
multidisciplinary effort because i think
at least i've tried that without knowing
that that was what it was called but i
think it was a good idea
[Music]
no i want to say i have exactly the same
experience so every time that i have
been working with a medical doctor and
the the funny thing is that they come to
you first because they have all these
omics data they are so excited about
right
and then when you bring
a kind of complex model to them
they are scared and then they once
they they they come back and say yeah
but which is the biomarker right so
because it's kind of too complex right
so one way they want like both right so
the one that you look at everything but
at the end of the day that you come with
a simple question with a simple answer
all right so that's the paradox a little
bit right
um
and i have i have failed always that i
have when when i have uh provided my you
know multiomics of
omics analysis results to a medical
doctor and help and ask for help in the
interpretation of the data
they were never able to give me that
right because it was too complex so i
think that this is a two ways thing
right so we need to understand from them
what they need but i think also that
at some point there is a need for some
more quantitative training of these
people that are also that are looking
into complex diseases you want to see
you know
more so
you need that this training is is
multi-disciplinary in the conversation
but a little bit more uh trying to reach
the the knowledge domain of the other to
be able to to communicate better and to
be able to
to oh to give back what they are asking
you that you give them
yeah so i really like the idea of this
tran transversal learning like at some
point everyone should touch a bit of
data analysis or like doing research and
so when i was doing the postdoc in
canada in tickets i saw the md phds and
how they interact with the clinical part
and the and the research part and it was
amazing
i go back to mexico and honestly the
medical community is a bit more worried
about people not dying
so it's really hard to to make them
collaborate with you in research
because they also haven't done research
seriously ever they had like a little
class maybe in the underground
and mexico
md school is undergrad level so maybe
they had like one class of scientific
methods and that was it and
so it's
it's a struggle because you want them to
collaborate so we can do
like very good level genomic science in
good patients in mexico but it's also
hard to make them collaborate because
they don't see the point
because they like reading the papers but
they they don't really understand why
should that be done in mexico so like
that's that's a challenge but having
transversal classes would make a
difference
that's
so i wanted to transition from this
topic to the next topic
um
which has to do with how do we
do our trainings that we actually engage
people from other groups from
underrepresented groups et cetera
i um
i want to say that even though
you want people to understand the
biology you want them to understand the
statistics you want them to be good at
the computer science it's too much to
ask
and what i think is perhaps a very good
thing to think about is that many of us
have entered into this field gradually
we've entered into it from the where
we're comfortable so i started as a
graph algorithms person
ron you are probably the same right so
there are a bunch of us who have entered
into this field and gradually gotten
hooked
and gradually made our ways into being
able to be contributing things that are
valuable
if we have the same patience
we can actually do great things and that
would include taking people who are
smart and driven
but not knowledgeable about biology
statistics and computer science and
giving them opportunities to get
involved in projects and to participate
and to gradually get hooked and to
eventually make really big contributions
but i don't think we should be thinking
about they have to start as
undergraduates and then we have to be
able to do this and that will never make
a difference in terms of the diversity
in our communities if we have such a
standard
thanks and i think
yeah one
historical perspective
that may be
helpful
physics became
aware of mathematics about
around 1900
and it took
i don't know 50 years
and by now
there is a
applied mathematics department which are
actually
doing the kind of physics
the mathematics of physics and
practically every physicist is an
applied mathematician but there is this
difference so the more advanced the more
method development is done in applied
math department but on the other hand
every
physicist is mathematics aware and i
think this will happen is happening
gradually to biology as well that
more and more biologists are becoming
aware of computation
while at the same time we still need the
professionals in
departments of
computational biology it's a long
process but i think we are heading this
way
yeah i think it was going back to the
previous comments about
interdisciplinarity and having people to
do that and i i just wanted a second
you know these interactions that
i think if you want to foster these
changes quickly then using the next
generation and enabling them to do that
is a very good way i mean we've been
at the mbl had this interdisciplinary
poster programs between two laboratories
and
i think the the best experience of
people in the lab if they come in and do
these science that i would never do and
the other lab would never do
and then they do it between these two
labs and fields and bring things forward
it's been super enriching um and it's
excellent for the fellow because they're
in abel they have a lot more control and
ownership of their science and it's
super exciting for the participating
labs because they get pushed in new
directions so i think this tenderm
relationships between fields between
labs and enabling trainees
um
to break these bridges as maybe a way to
to save a little bit of time although i
agree it will take it will take time to
get there
just had a comment about the increasing
diversity and
the students and and i thought it was a
really interesting point but and one
thing i've seen i worked with a lot of
students actually who came from mexico
from unam which has a really great
undergraduate program in computational
biology really phenomenal
and one thing i've appreciated is that
if you can get the students
you know productive inner research area
quicker
then there are labs who are happy to
have them and pay for them and i think
that that's one consideration that we
have to think about for these students
which is you know they can't do a
master's that they're going to pay for
while they retrain in a different area
and then spend a little bit more time
and you know they the family sometimes
expects that you know they're going to
support themselves and and they have
expectations and so if we can get them
to a point that labs will appreciate
them
quicker then then they can have more
runway to to do exactly what what you
were saying which is to you know broaden
slowly their their expertise base which
is a long process but
we kind of need to get them there just
because of the practicalities of
you know the the way you know funding
works and and and their own economic
situation so something i've absorbed
yeah
it's interesting i've i've thought a lot
about this over my career and like you
know to some of ji ping's points you
know you can't train somebody in
everything it just becomes impossible
and i think the
the best
strength that i've seen or the sort of
the most success i've seen is when you
have the right group of experts each
with their own depth working together
and speaking the same language but you
know that's not uh you know someone
walks into the office we solve a problem
and a month later it's over this these
are like five-year 10-year
collaborations that are at least in my
experience the ones that finally reach
fruition and so
um
and tony really love what you said i
think the
the story that i've been hearing again
and again from talking to people about
how do we increase diversity in genomics
for example um
is it's not around teaching someone a
class or a couple classes but it's about
creating pathways that they can follow
and and that means not just you know
creating the educational opportunities
for them to take and to follow their own
path and some might become deep
dispersed some might be
multidisciplinary um but also creating
training environments where they see
people that look like them teaching the
classes creating research opportunities
right it's it's it's you know very much
about the experience what i'm hearing
again against my colleagues it's really
more about after a student takes a class
that it's clear for them what the next
step is the next step is the next step
is and giving them that path and making
that path easier for people to follow
allows them to engage in these five ten
fifteen year efforts that it takes to
really
maximize it
so that is a very good point and
actually it's something that i've been
discussing with uh some peers in latin
america
because there's a lot of funding for
this capacity building courses there's a
lot we appreciate it don't stop doing
them please uh
but at some point this capacity building
hardly translates into collaborations
it's like people will come they jump
they teach a class for a week they
trained them in genomics bioinformatics
ngs whatever
and then you see grants from these
people where they say i have been
teaching in uruguay for 1000 years and
they are awesome and it's like okay but
you have no collaborations from that
country so what have you been doing
there you go teach you never talk to
them again
so these paths like how how do we keep
training these people
and investing in that capacity building
and actually at some point bring them
into being collaborators these are
smart people they just happen to be in
in a lower advantage position
but
how can we bring them into being real
collaborators and not just receivers of
our knowledge um but that's those paths
uh i would like them to be created i
don't know how to
at least that's a discussion that i
think we should be
having
yeah yeah maybe some kind of long-term
community like people will buy in and
they you don't precisely like this
program where now um people come
every several years and renew friendship
making new friends and then you know it
needs to have a sustained life yeah one
one of the things that the italian
government does for their phd
scholarships that they that they offer
is that you're during your phd you're
you're allowed up to 18 months in a in a
lab abroad like in a group abroad right
that's actually how i do work with
sandrine and i ended up here right and
that to me is you know really a good
model because it goes a little bit of
what uh oliver said before where you
know if two labs collaborate then you're
creating a new science that maybe the
individual labs didn't think of
and you know these two labs if they're
like from you know one side you know
maybe a less advantaged country
and then they come to the us and the
western europe then then you can really
build these sort of like collaborations
that they maybe they go back they
graduate and when they graduate they can
do a postdoc or you know they at least
have like
you know papers or other collaborations
to show that they have like done good
science with you know so so that to me
would be like if you know if there's u.s
funding to
kind of like uh um uh you know that that
would be like something like a semester
full year
and it's free right i mean the thing is
like you can we just you know my advisor
at the time just emailed sandrine
without knowing her and it's like do you
want a free student she said yes right
because i mean why not
i mean
one really huge specific problem is that
you can't get
nih fellowships or nsf fellowships if
you're not an american citizen um
so that means half the students in my
lab are totally ineligible uh we can
probably
collectively pressure
uh politicians to try to change that i
think it's the kind of thing that makes
perfect sense to change and
if we could get that accomplished in
five years it would i think be
transformative for bringing more diverse
audiences into
at least the universities in america
[Music]
those are really would be terrific tools
but they're only permanent residents or
u.s citizens so that's that would be a
good thing to change yeah
the session went by so fast so i don't
know if anyone has
yeah concluding comments
i i appreciate the comment about a
sustained relationship i think a lot of
what people were talking about was about
the pipeline and getting people in or
checking boxes but the key is to have uh
people stay in the fields and
do great work and for the
environment to be supportive there's no
point to have a pipeline if people feel
like they don't belong
exactly we have a lot of work to do
there yeah i think i think at the end
human capital is the best capital
oh that was a lot a lot of terrific
comments very lively insightful
discussion so so really thank you so
much
to all of you um for for contributing
all your thoughts
to the discussion and thanks to all the
participants in the audience i really
really enjoyed the panel a lot of things
to think about so big round of applause
for our panelists
[Applause]
so that's it for the first day so our
next